for much of the past century
architecture was under the spell of a
famous doctrine
formfollow's function had become
modernity's ambitious manifesto and
detrimental straitjacket
as it liberated architecture from the
decorative
but condemned it to utilitarian rigor
and restrained purpose
of course architecture is about function
but i want to remember a re-writing of
this phrase by bernard chumi and i want
to propose a completely different
quality
if form follows fiction
we could think of architecture and
buildings as a space of stories
stories of the people that live there of
the people that work in these buildings
and we could start to imagine the
experiences our buildings create
in this sense i'm interested in fiction
not as the implausible
but as the real as the reality of what
architecture means for the people that
live in it and with it
our buildings are prototypes ideas for
how the space of living or how the space
of working could be different
and how space of culture or space of
media could look like today
our buildings are real they're being
built they're an explicit engagement in
physical reality and conceptual
possibility
i think of our architecture as
organizational structures
at their core is indeed structural
thinking like a system how can we
arrange things in both a functional and
experiential way
how can we create structures that
generate a series of relationships and
narratives
and how convictive stories of the
inhabitants and users of our buildings
script the architecture
while the architecture scripts those
stories at the same time
and here comes the second term into play
what i call narrative hybrids
structures of multiple simultaneous
stories that unfold throughout the
buildings we create
so we could think of architecture
as complex systems of relationships
both on a programmatic and functional
way
and in an experiential and emotive or
social way
this is the headquarters for china's
national broadcaster which i designed
together with ramco house at oma
when i first arrived in beijing in 2002
the city planners showed us this image a
forest of several hundred skyscrapers to
emerge in the central business district
except at that time only a handful of
them existed
so we had to design in a context that we
knew almost nothing about except one
thing it would all be about verticality
of course the skyscraper is vertical
it's a profoundly hierarchical structure
the top always the best the bottom the
worst and the taller you are the better
so it seems
and we wanted to ask ourselves could the
building be about a completely different
quality could it undo this hierarchy
and could it be about a system that is
more about collaboration than rather
than isolation so we took this needle
and bend it back into itself into a loop
of interconnected activities
our idea was to bring all aspects of
television making into one single
structure news program production
broadcasting research and training
administration all into a circuit of
interconnected activities where people
would meet in a process of exchange and
collaboration
i still very much like this image it
reminds of biology classes if you
remember the human body with all its
organs and circulatory systems like at
school and suddenly you think of
architecture no longer as built
substance
but as an organism as a life form
and as you start to dissect this
organism you can identify a series of
primary technical clusters
program production broadcasting center
and news
those are tightly intertwined with
social clusters meeting rooms canteens
chat areas informal spaces for people to
meet and exchange
so the organizational structure of this
building was a hybrid between the
technical and the social the human and
the performative
and of course we used the loop of the
building as a circulatory system to
thread everything together and to allow
both visitors and staff to experience
all these different functions in a great
unity
with 473 000 square meters it is one of
the largest buildings ever built in the
world
it has a population of over 10 000
people and of course this is a scale
that exceeds the comprehension of many
things and the scale of typical
architecture so we stopped work for a
while and sat down and cut 10 000 little
sticks and glued them onto a model just
simply to confront ourselves with what
that quantity actually meant
but of course it's not a number it is
the people it is a community that
inhabits the building and in order to
both comprehend this but also script
this architecture we identified five
characters hypothetical characters and
we followed them throughout their day
in a life in this building
thought of where they would meet what
they would experience so it was a way to
script and design the building but of
course also to communicate its
experiences this was part of an
exhibition with a museum of modern art
in both new york and beijing
this is the main broadcast control room
a technical installation so large it can
broadcast over 200 channels
simultaneously
and this is how the building stands
in beijing today
its first broadcast live the london
olympics 2012 after it had been
completed from the outside for the
beijing olympics
and you can see at the very tip of this
75 meter cantilever those three little
circles and they're indeed part of a
public loop that goes through the
building and they're a piece of glass
that you can stand on and watch the city
pass by below you in slow motion
the building has become part of everyday
life in beijing it is there it has also
become a very popular backdrop
for wedding photography
but it's its most important moment is is
maybe still this one that's beijing is
similar to timeout a magazine that
broadcasts what is happening in town
during the week and suddenly you see the
building portrayed no longer as physical
matter but actually as an urban actor as
part of a series of personas that define
the life of the city
so architecture suddenly assumes the
quality
of
a player of some something that writes
stories and perform stories and i think
that
could be one of its primary meanings um
that we believe in but of course there's
another story to this building it is the
story of the people that made it 400
engineers and architects that i was
guiding over almost a decade of
collaborative work that we spent
together in scripting this building in
imagining its reality and ultimately
getting it built in china
this is a residential development in
singapore large scale
if we look at singapore like most of
asia and more and more of the world
of course it is dominated by the tower
a typology that indeed creates more
isolation than connectedness and i
wanted to ask how could we think about
living not only in terms of the privacy
and individuality of ourselves and our
apartment but in an idea of a collective
how could we think about creating a
communal environment in which sharing
things was as great as having your own
the typical answer to the question we
had to design 1040 apartments would have
looked like this 24-story height limit
given by the planning authorities 12
towers with nothing but residual in
between
a very tight system that although the
tower isolates it doesn't even give you
privacy because you're so close to the
next one that it is very questionable
what the qualities of this would be
so i propose to topple the towers throw
the vertical into the horizontal and
stack them up
and what looks like a bit random from
the side if you look from the viewer
point of the helicopter you can see its
organizational structure is actually a
hexagonal grid in which these horizontal
building blocks are stacked up
to create huge outdoor courtyards
central spaces for the community
programmed with a variety of amenities
and functions
and you see that these courtyards are
not hermetically sealed spaces they're
open permeable they're interconnected we
call the project the interlace thinking
that we interlace and interconnect the
human beings
and the spaces alike
and the detailed quality of everything
we designed was about animating the
space and giving the space to the
inhabitants and in fact it was a system
where we would layer
primarily communal spaces stacked to
more and more individual and private
spaces
so we would open up a spectrum between
the collective and the individual a
little piece of maths if we count all
the green that we left on the ground
minus the footprint of the buildings
and we would add back the green of all
the terraces we have 112 percent green
space so more nature than not having
built a building
and of course this little piece of math
shows you that we are multiplying the
space available to those who live there
this is in fact the 13th floor of one of
these terraces so you see new datum
planes new ground planes for social
activity
we've paid a lot of attention
to sustainability
in the tropics the sun is the most
important thing to pay attention to and
in fact it is seeking protection from
the sun
we first proved that all apartments
would have sufficient daylight
throughout the year
we then went on to optimize the glazing
of the facades to minimize the energy
consumption of the building
but most importantly we could prove
that through the geometry of the
building design the building itself
would provide sufficient shading to the
courtyards so that those would be usable
throughout the entire year we further
placed water bodies along the prevailing
wind corridors so that evaporative
cooling would create microclimates that
again would enhance the quality of those
spaces available for the inhabitants
and it was the idea of creating this
variety of choices
a freedom
to think where you would want to be
where you would want to escape maybe
within the own complexity of the complex
in which you live
we're coming from asia to europe a
building for a german media company
based in berlin
transitioning from the traditional print
media to the digital media
and its ceo asked a few very pertinent
questions
why would anyone today still want to go
to the office because you can actually
work anywhere and how could a digital
identity of a company be embodied
in a building
we created not only an object but at the
center of this object we created a giant
space and this space
was about the experience of a collective
the experience of collaboration and of
togetherness
communication interaction as the center
of a space that in itself
would float like what we call the
collaborative cloud in the middle of the
building
surrounded by an envelope of standard
modular offices
so with only a few steps from your quiet
work desk you could participate in the
giant collective experience of the
central space
finally we come to london
a project commissioned by the london
legacy development corporation of the
mayor of london
we were asked to undertake a study and
investigate the potential of a site out
in stratford in the olympic park
in the 19th century prince albert had
created albertopolis
and boris johnson thought of creating
olympicopolis
the idea was to bring together some of
britain's greatest institutions
some international ones and to create a
new system of synergies
prince albert as yet
created albertopolis in the 19th century
thought of showcasing all achievements
of mankind bringing arts and science
closer together
and he built exhibition wrote a linear
sequence of those institutions
but of course today's society has moved
on from there we no longer live in a
world in which everything is as clearly
delineated or separated from each other
we live in a world in which
boundaries start to blur between the
different domains and in which
collaboration and interaction becomes
far more important
than keeping separations
so we wanted to think of
a giant culture machine a building that
would orchestrate and animate
the various domains but allow them to
interact and collaborate
at the base of it is a very simple
module a ring module it can function as
a double loaded corridor has daylight
has ventilation it can be glazed over
and turned into a giant exhibition or
performance space
these modules were stacked together with
the idea that almost any function could
over time occupy any of these modules so
institutions could shrink or contract as
of course the future of culture is in a
way the most uncertain of all
this is how the building sits adjacent
to the aquatic center opposite the
olympic stadium
and you can see how its cantileving
volumes project out and engage the
public space and how its courtyards
animate the public inside
the idea was to create a complex system
in which
institutional entities could maintain
their own identity in which they would
not be subsumed in a singular volume
here's a scale comparison to the centro
pompido in paris it both shows the
enormous scale and potential of the
project but also the difference here it
is a multiplicity of a heterogeneous
structure
in which different entities can interact
without losing their own identity
and it was this thought to create an
organizational structure that would
allow for multiple narratives to be
scripted for those in the educational
parts that create
and think culture for those that present
the visual arts the dance and for the
public to be admitted into all of this
with a series of possible trajectories
to script their own reading of these
narratives
and their own experience
and i want to end on a project that is
very small in a way very different
a floating cinema in the ocean of
thailand friends of mine had founded a
film festival
and i thought
if we think of the stories and
narratives of movies we should also
think of the narratives of the people
that watch it
so i designed a small modular floating
platform
based on the techniques of local
fishermen how they built their lobster
and fish farms we collaborated with the
local community
and built out of recycled materials of
their own this fantastical floating
platform that gently moved in the ocean
as we watched films from the british
film archive 1904 alice in wonderland
for example
the most primordial experiences of the
audience that merged with the stories of
the movies
i believe that
architecture exceeds the domain of
physical matter of the built environment
but is really about how we want to live
our lives how we script our own stories
and those of others
thank you
[Music]